wir haben mittlerweile herausgefunden
was hinter diesem posting steckt und
zwar plant michael wendler eine
erklärung
er möchte erklären wie es zu diesem
video was wir ja eben noch mal schön
zusammengefasst gesehen haben indem er
corona leugnet die bundesregierung
kritisiert und auch seinen damaligen
noch-arbeitgeber rtl er möchte halt
erklären wie es dazu kam zu diesem video
was jetzt genau der inhalt sein wird
also was seine begründung dafür ist das
wissen wir noch nicht aber wir wissen
dass es kommen soll diese erklärung am
dritten november und laut unseren
informationen steht sogar eine rückkehr
des wendlers im raum eine rückkehr auf
die auf das parkett und eine rückkehr
nach deutschland wir haben natürlich
auch mit seinem manager krampe darüber
gesprochen und der bestätigte und das am
dritten november eine erklärung kommen
soll und der wendler immer ja für eine
überraschung gut sein
ja du sagst gerade sogar ein comeback
auf die showbühnen zurück wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass das
tatsächlich erfolgreich ist segment hat
gezeigt er kann es gab schon comebacks
von ihnen aber diesmal die situation ja
doch ernst war die situation ist sehr
ernst und herr krampe hat zu uns gesagt
wenn der wendler einsicht zeigt denn
sieht er auch noch chancen für ihn
ich sehe das ein bisschen anders herr
wendler hat nicht nur die
bundesregierung kritisiert corona
geleugnet und gesagt dass alle medien
gleichgeschaltet sind unzensiert werden
er hat auch alle seine werbepartner und
geschäftspartner mit solchen dingen
verprellt das muss man einfach sagen er
hat verbrannte erde hinterlassen und das
wieder gutzumachen
das würde ja nicht nur eine
distanzierung bedeuten so was kann man
einfach gar nicht so schnell wieder
gutmachen
natürlich kann es sein dass seine fans
weiterhin zu ihm stehen
und er chance hat wieder ein neues album
rauszubringen nur ganz ehrlich wenn man
sich die kommentare auf seinem instagram
account anguckt da hat er ja dieses
posting gemacht auch ein foto mit lauge
veröffentlicht das schreiben die leute
so was drunter wie du bist auf dem
falschen kanal sich michael g wieder zu
telegraph
duale hut träger also ich bezweifle dass
das wirklich klappt ich bin gespannt auf
die erklärung ich bezweifle dass er noch
chancen in der deutschen stahlbranche
hat trotzdem wenn er jetzt zurückkommt
er muss ja auch eigentlich zurück er hat
hier ja auch noch ein paar gerichtliche
dinge zu klären wie man das auch einer
der gründe sein warum er jetzt
offensichtlich ein rückflugticket nach
deutschland gebucht hat und doch nicht
für immer das land verlassen hat
das ist ganz schwer zu sagen weil ihm
drohen hier ja also er hat ja einen
verfahren am hals es geht um ein
insolvenzverfahren wurde ja auf
bewährung verurteilt dann hat er ist
eine berufung gegangen das urteil ist
noch nicht rechtskräftig
zwei termine hat er schon abgesagt der
nächste termin steht aus und da wird
jetzt spannend gewartet ob er zum
nächsten termin kommt der er bereits
angesetzt ist oder ob er den wieder
platzen lässt dann droht ihm ja im
schlimmsten fall sogar haft bei der
einreise das sind alles fragen und
natürlich kann das eine rolle spielen
natürlich kann es sein dass er
eingesehen hat dass er sich so nicht
verhalten kann und dass es besser ist
wenn er sich der deutschen justiz stellt
das alles ist möglich
am ende des tages ist es glaube ich aber
auch so dass er vielleicht jetzt auch
gemerkt hat dass er einfach man sagt ja
manchmal so schön über den beckenrand
gepasst hat vielleicht merkt dass jetzt
einfach auch weil wir haben zum beispiel
gesehen laura hat jetzt am wochenende
auf instagram das erste mal wieder
werbung gemacht für fake lashes also für
künstliche wimpern und da gab es gleich
einen richtigen schützt doch da hat sich
zum beispiel eine frau geäußert auf der
seite des herstellers die jemanden an
cupid 19 verloren hat ein
familienmitglied die geschrieben hat sie
kann das halt überhaupt nicht verstehen
wie ein unternehmen jemanden der mit so
an menschen wie dem wendler zusammenlebt
und sich nicht klar distanziert die
möglichkeit hat werbung zu machen und
das ist ja genau das große problem dass
die menschen das nicht verstehen dass
sie auch sauer sind und ja ich bin
wirklich
wir gucken mit großen gespannten augen
auf den dritten november mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dir das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren